we were experimenting with psychedelics
as much as we were playing music in
philosophy leaving yourself open to
possibility and leaving yourself open
the magic acid-test experience really
perform them as a group Martin the
Grateful Dead the band Forge during the
acid tests of the 1960's that grew to
become one of the most popular live acts
in American history is the subject of a
new for our film by Academy Award
nominated director Ameer bar left
there's a sex drugs rock and roll but
also a kind of a different attitude
towards Fame and towards the
relationship with fans that I think
people whether you like the band or not
are going to find informative and
interesting you know when I was a
teenager picking from the palette of
cultural options out there and you know
picking from stuff that MTV wanted to
serve me or exploring the Grateful Dead
the Grateful Dead represented a kind of
a high standard of honest music you know
that I changed my life and my attitude
towards music and I know I'm not alone
if you went in the audience we were
included in the experience
feel back you should have known
something was coming when there were
more people outside they show the word
show I'm a lefty right so when I hear
that Tucker Carlson and Ann Coulter call
themselves again it's my natural
response is to say no they don't get it
but that's I think long that's not
that's that's the wrong attitude that I
have and and if you look at what the
Grateful Dead were about it was a
radical inclusivity and and there was no
one way to be a dead head everybody was
welcome motorcyclists newbies gate
Crashers psycho right-wingers I think
they're the musical Statue of Liberty
you know because they invited everybody
to participate not just to watch to
participate there was a strong belief
that if leaderless who was the charge
well I'm so glad you asked
there were times when I wasn't sorry
times and Jerry would recharge a truck
that had a blown carburetor that
carburetor is the boss I think Jerry was
radically anti-authoritarian and all the
guys are in the band and so you know
when when people began to elect them to
be authorities they had a natural
concern and skepticism around that and I
think that's healthy I wish more people
in power were concerned about power and
wielding power you know and I think
that's what gave the Grateful Dead its
longevity it was never about one person
or seven people it was something more
pluralistic the band had a healthy
skepticism around a kind of top-down
authoritarian approach to community the
Grateful Dead famously let people take
their music and you know keep bootlegs
of them for free and I think you know
that was part and parcel of an ethos
with the Grateful Dead that you know
that you trust people that made us feel
like we were participating in something
and that we were trustworthy and you
know of course that that drew more
people to them it was very American
you could you know you weren't being
told what to do you were being asked to
do the right thing and being made
responsible for your own actions it's
not up to us to defiant the grateful did
it's this living breathing thing and
that's one of the parts of this magic
not defined it is that it becomes
everything the Grateful Dead had nothing
to do it created a community around them
they just made space for it you know
they made space by not taking up all the
room with themselves and their own egos
you know that's that's like so
refreshing and missing from popular
culture today they you know there's this
great line in the film where Jerry says
what I loved about the acid test is
people weren't there to see us and you
think you know would you ever hear a
rock star say the best thing about those
early shows is we weren't the center of
attention it set a tone that you know is
why they're still here today
you